hi guys hi fun film Thank You Owen for
you what would you say is the best part
about being a child actor um I think the
best part is that you can look forward
to what you have later and you can
really I don't say the even control your
future but you can really take it step
in it and see like if you want to do
scary things yeah you can see if you can
focus on that I like these types of
movies these are my favorite what would
you say is the best part about working
with Jack
he's just so fun he's hilarious you
trained him well it's very yeah it's
very embarrassing when he has to say
what's great about me well I'm sitting
right next to him love it you love it
come on we had a great time working on
this movie and Owen has that magic spark
that it's like when you love to put on a
show and you'd love to get up in front
of the camera and like create scenarios
I know what that's about you know and it
it's not every every kid that has the
courage to really just do that and he's
got and we were we were having a blast
the hotel Eli said one of his favorite
scenes was seeing you caught in the
pumpkin is that a favorite scene for
years the pumpkin was one of the funnest
scenes because it was all three of us
you me and Kate working our magic spells
and fighting tooth and nail for our
lives against these invisible pumpkins
that we had to trust that they're gonna
do some fantastic special effects later
but at the time we just look like idiots
like it would be so funny to see that
scene without any special effects but
that was maybe my favorite scene to
shoot it oh man if you could cast one
spell each of you what would it be and
why oh I'd like to turn a lie into a doc
for the day
Wow
Eli a duck for a day just for a day
that's not bad
yeah that's pretty nice I think I would
cast a spell to mmm have my boys just
wake up really easily and get dressed
and brush their teeth without me having
to say anything every morning and just
jump in the car let's go to school that
that's off I think that's every parent's
wish that's a pretty powerful spell I
don't think I'm that advanced as a
warlock yet and last question I know
that they're talking about just Batman
and wanting a villain and the penguin
would that be a role you'd be interested
in I know Danny DeVito did it in the 90
is there talk of me as the penguin I
mean oh uh yeah that would be a role
that would be fun
you'd be into it I mean I hate to put
myself out there and say that because
then when I don't get that part
it was Oh Jack tried to get the thing
Anderson maybe that would be good well
thank you so much